but after the savory experience
I don't know how good sweets can be
and now rice krispies seems like
something I would usually eat the consistency
I expected it to be quite crunchy
instead I could make us the molds no but whoever
makes it should know of chocolate
you can  use as a paste to make
the denture stick the gum or
not badly I have no economic means
I was expecting totally something else very
salty just disgusting
I am looking forward to paul belli slimy years
270 calories there is the taste does
not match the smell at all though  it's
not bad a whole density road is too much
of everything no sponsor of
the official team of america opts bad
because but the cracker tastes like I pose from a
few graves now I understand why they have
so much energy the americans are
last you will become big and strong
saurian are  candies for children and
pictured there are the
creepiest men I have ever seen in
fraud this thing you can play with it
better let's say how  are
i like them want to wear cycle paths a
lot already in the afternoon i think they are
clever willy wonka because they
made them a palomba
i don't know about strawberry type medicines
for children i trusted this
innocent pink color but i was wrong i
think i have a cavity after  this
experience because I already feel so
much more fat than when I
came here eaten some real sweets never
felt a tir at this let's talk about it